[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo heute gibt es direkt vor unseren
kanal brisantes thema es geht um genau
jene welche die plattform gehört diese
politik haust du wirst dir vielleicht
schon denken können um wen es geht
alfabet wenn dir alphabet aber nicht
sagt dann kommen hier die fakten korrekt
aktuell sind wir auf youtube aber
youtube ist ein teil von google und eben
dies ist wiederum anteils von alfabet
ein riesiger mischkonzern da überall ein
fuss übertrat youtube google maps google
android und study all dies gehört dazu
und ist doch nur ein kleiner teil von
alfabet was sicherlich schon eine ganze
reihe unserer videos gesehen und daher
ist die auch bekannt wie viele facetten
das internet haben kann
für die meisten ist es trotz allem sehr
beeindruckend zu erfahren das ist fünf
big player gibt von dem sie es direkt
kontrolliert wird oder in irgendeiner
form abhängig ist diese fünf sind
alphabet zu backen facebook amazon apple
und microsoft gmbh am oder big pack
unter diesen namen sind sich auch
bekannt jetzt aber wirst du dich frage
ist wo ist da das problem ohne google
gibt es doch wieso als politiker nicht
und so verhält es sich mit fast allen
kanälen wieder gefallen die meisten
haben alleine oder mit freunden
angefangen videos aufzunehmen und
youtube gab ihnen die möglichkeit diese
mit der ganzen welt zu teilen
wusstest du dass das erste video auf
youtube 180 sekunden das video ist
mätresse veröffentlicht von einem
mitgründer von youtube ohne youtube wäre
es natürlich möglich gewesen eine eigene
website zu haben
vermutlich wäre aber super unbekannt und
nicht zu erreichen hätten wir 1000 euro
in werbung investieren müssen
diese summe können wir so ziemlich jede
andere youtuber sich aber nicht leisten
das bedeutet also kein geld kann wieso
alten mittig die google suchmaschine hat
auch viele gute aspekte aber sowie mit
ihnen oder gibt es eine helle und eine
dunkle seite die ein beispiel die
google-suche hat einen weltweiten
marktanteil von über 80 prozent
nur in wenigen ländern ist dem nicht so
russland wo sie mit yandex konkurriert
und china wo sie halt einfach verboten
ist für den rest der welt ist google die
unangefochtene nummer eins in großen
ländern wie spanien indien und brasilien
gegenüber 90 prozent aller suchanfragen
an google mit anderen worten opel hält
ein globales monopol auf suchanfragen
nun stellst du dir die frage ob das
wirklich ein problem darstellt nun wie
bei so vielem illi dies im auge des
betrachters
anders als zum beispiel microsoft konnte
google seine position und macht
erreichen indem es einen qualitativ
hochwertigen ja fantastischen service
angeboten hat er als seinesgleichen
suchte und welche konsequenzen sind
daraus erwachsen nun du wirst dich jetzt
sicher fragen welche rolle spielt es
denn überhaupt welche suchmaschine ich
benutze hier mal was darüber zum
nachdenken
die suchmaschine ist unser tor zum rest
des internets ohne sie müssten wir die
genauen adressen jeder einzelnen
webseite kennen die wir besuchen wollen
und die vorher erwähnt ohne googles
suche würden auch wir wohl nicht
gefunden werden
aber wenn wir nicht auf der ersten seite
der google suche auftauchen ist fast so
als ob wir gar nicht existieren würden
google hat also viel macht darüber was
wir sehen und besonders was wir nicht
sehen
in der theorie ist diese macht nicht
inhärent gut oder schlecht kann aber zu
schwerwiegenden folgen führen alle diese
erfolgen wäre folgende
konnte reicht die eu kommission
verhängte strafe von 2,42 milliarden
euro gegen google wegen missbrauchs der
marktbeherrschenden stellung als
suchmaschine
der vorwurf dreht sich um die illegale
begünstigung des eigenen shopping
dienstes im vergleich zu konkurrenten
dieses jahr liegt google vor gericht
berufung ein gegen dies und andere
bußgelder
die europäische kommission hat google
mit diesen bußgeldern belegt wegen
missbrauchs ihrer marktposition wer
tatsächlich recht hat ist schwer zu
sagen ende jeden dieser stelle europas
position ist dass google seine
marktposition missbraucht um musik ist
so dass die google suche und das
android-betriebssystem ihr eigentum sind
und die daher damit machen können was
sie wollen ist auch logisch in einem
apple store hängt ja auch nicht dasselbe
plakat für das neueste handy von samsung
selbst wie er das team hinter visual
politik haben da keine einheitliche
meinung und vielleicht denkst du dir
gerade aber was ist wenn das nur eine
strategie der eu war um ein
amerikanisches unternehmen zu bestrafen
tja darauf kann ich nur ein gegner
google kämpft nicht nur in der eu mit
dem start schon immer folgendes an
das us justizministerium und elf
bundesstaaten und werfen google
kartellrechtsverstöße vor
es nutzt seine enorme größe aus um ein
legales monopol aufzubauen im bereich
der werbung bei suchergebnissen
diese und die eu anklage sind sich sehr
ähnlich auch in diesem fall wird es
höchstwahrscheinlich jahre dauern bis
ihr ein urteil seele und wie im fall der
eu gibt es auch hier keine einfache
antwort auf die frage wer gewinnen wird
google ist aber nicht alleine andere big
tech konzerne sind mit ähnlichen klagen
konfrontiert damit das alles aber nicht
zu kompliziert wird liegt unser fokus
heute auf dem alphabet konzern präziser
google die fragen die wir heute in
diesem video beantworten wollen laufen
also woher kommt dieser rechtsstreit zu
welchen anteil stecken da politische
motive hinter und wie viel davon hat
wirtschaftliche gründe
und wie funktionieren diese ganzen im
monopol gesetze das große dilemma des
kapitalismus
das konzept das hinter kapitalismus
steht lautet wie folgt gründe ein
unternehmen welches eine gute
dienstleistung anbietet und sich damit
von den konkurrenten abhebt und wenn du
bedeutend besser ist als alle anderen
könnte es passieren dass du nach einer
weile praktisch der einzige west der
diese dienstleistung anbietet ja das
klingt es vielleicht einfach ist aber
ganz und gar nicht wenn die meisten
monopole auf dieser welt werden von
staaten erzeugt in deutschland zum
beispiel hatte die bundesbahn bis 1993
das eisenbahn monopol die deutsche post
ag bis 2008 das riecht beförderungs
monopol und die telekom bis 1998 das
monopol auf telefondienst diese monopole
waren gesetzlich verankert wettbewerb
also einfach verboten
manche monopol aber entstehen auch durch
das system des freien marktes an sich
der begriff des freien marktes wird
gerne von wirtschaftsliberalen
politikern verwendet die bloße existenz
von monopolen jedoch ist gibt für eines
der kern konzepte des kapitalismus den
wettbewerb denn ohne konkurrenten keine
preis und qualitäts kampf zwischen den
unternehmen ein unternehmen kann ihr
preis und qualität diktieren wenn es
keine konkurrenten gibt es hier die
gleiche dienstleistung oder das gleiche
produkt günstiger oder ein besserer
qualität anbieten können dass größere
unternehmen kann auch potenzielle
rivalen einfach aufkaufen um sein
monopol zu schützen ein hervorragendes
beispiel wäre der kauf von instagram
durch facebook wirkt es sich gut
das schlechte auf den markt aus wenn
facebook seine größten konkurrenten
schluckt nun lasst es nicht beantworten
hier kommen die facts monopolist braucht
und wie kartellgesetze eben dies
verhindern sollen dafür sehen wir uns
einen der vorgang ist an den ersten fünf
wenige microsoft vielleicht endest du
dich ja daran in den neunziger jahren
war das monopol für pc betriebssysteme
und büroanwendungen fest in der hand von
microsoft anders als google hatte
microsoft sein monopol jedoch nicht
durch die konkurrenzlos gute qualität
seiner produkte erreicht ganz im
gegenteil statt mit maximalem nutzwert
für seine kunden zu punkten
konzentrierter ist alle kräfte auf ihre
umzingelung durch knebelverträge und
eine sehr destruktive bekämpfung des
wettbewerbs durch kuppel lose
geschäftspraktiken im kern ging es darum
die käufer und nutzer von software in
eine sogenannte login situation zu
bringen in der sie keine andere wahl
mehr hatten als microsoft produkte zu
kaufen diese von rücksichtsloser profit
gier gespeiste geschäftspolitik der
herren wc und die voller spielte sich
derart krass am rande der illegalität ab
dass schließlich das us
justizministerium und 18 bundesstaaten
auf den plan traten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier stieß ministerium reicht
kartellklage gegen microsoft wegen
unrechtmäßiger monopolisierung der
computersoftware märkte eine so jetzt
ging's bill gates endlich an den kragen
nachdem die justiz viele jahre lang
seinen machenschaften zu gesehen hatte
die hauptpunkte der anklage gestanden
aus dem vorwurf des unlauteren
wettbewerbs illegal ist lucy wicks
klauseln und monopolen ist auch die
automatische einbindung des internet
explorer in jeder neuen installation von
windows ist ein gutes beispiel dafür wie
vor gericht enthüllten internen e-mails
hoher microsoft-manager kann man es
nicht dass magnus nachträgliche
konferenz auslöschen wollte durch
illegale dank den praktiken bill gates
und seine kollegen erfanden für diese
strategie sogar ein zynisches
firmeninternes motivation sleep mit dem
kürzel titel die 3ds standen für embrace
extend ex terminator bedeutete dass
makler store mit hilfe eines monopols
neue märkte zunächst mit einem zur
konkurrenz kovats ihren produkten tritt
dann jedoch zusätzliche kompatible
merkmale so viel und diese massiv
bewirkt damit anwender unabhängig werden
durch die so geschaffenen
interoperabilitäts probleme mit den
konkurrenzprodukten sollten diese völlig
ausgelöscht werden tja und für den
vorsitzenden richter jackson machen
damit der fall eindeutig ich zitiere
microsoft ist ein unternehmen mit einer
verinnerlichten geringschätzung sowohl
der wahrheit als auch des rechts welches
weniger bedeutender unternehmen
respektieren müssen es ist auch kein
unternehmen dessen leitende angestellte
keine skrupel haben
trügerische zeugenaussagen vorzutragen
um ihre missetaten hinter
fadenscheinigen verteidigungen und heute
löschen behauptungen zu verbergen
gemeint war damit natürlich auch bill
gates persönlich daher war jacksons
urteil eindeutig
microsoft soll sich zwei unternehmen
aufspalten microsoft jedoch legte
berufung ein und hatte glück ins weiße
haus zog mit george damit ihr wunsch ein
befreundeter präsident 1 natürlich kommt
den justizminister auswechselte und
diese entschlossenheit microsoft einfach
ein vergleich wie fünf jahre musste ist
konkurrenten zugang zu seinen
anwendungen zu schnellen gewähren das
war's kosten durch die juristische
querelen wurden microsofts
managementressourcen ziemlich stark
belastet vielleicht hätte es auch
deswegen eine reihe fatale
entscheidungen durch welche ist im zug
bei mobiltelefonen boots der internet
suche fast 20 jahre später da inzwischen
viele menschen das handy mehr benutzen
als ihren computer stehen nun google mit
android und apple mit ios in rente
microsoft hat seine zähne nicht verloren
ist aber ich bin der einzige weltweit
und nun zum elefanten der im raum steht
was wäre wenn die regierung nicht
eingegriffen hätte hätte microsoft dann
auch einmal obwohl im handy-markt denkt
mal darüber nach
nun aber zurück zu google hat google
überhaupt ein monopol und welche
monopolistische praxis wird google denn
eigentlich vorgeworfen kommt einmal zur
gründungsgeschichte von google denn da
sehen wir wo eigentlich das problem
[Musik]
don't be evil wusstest du dass google
von larry page und sergey brin gegründet
und lester ein einwanderer war
den grundstein legten die beiden 1995
als sie ihren innovativen algorithmus
pagerank entwickelt welcher den kern der
google-suchmaschine bildet und dafür
sorgt dass die suchergebnisse besser
waren als die der konkurrenz
übrigens die damalige vermieterin der
legendären ersten google garage ist
heute ziehen von youtube das internet
war damals noch neuland hat er erst 200
millionen nutzer
google war aber nicht die erste und war
nicht die einzige suchmaschine die
bekanntesten suchmaschinen damals waren
zum beispiel yandex und altavista da es
damals aber nicht ganz klar war wie man
nicht im internet öffentlich gemacht
waren investoren eher zögerlich dass das
internet die zukunft ist musste erst
einmal bewiesen werden und zeitgleich
muss nochmal der innovativste sagen
viele setzten in diesen wilden rennen
auf klassische konzept nicht zum
beispiel fernseher feind ist falsch
yahoo
[Musik]
und wenn du denkst du hättest den fehler
seines lebens gemacht weil du kein
amazon gekauft hast apple oder mit calls
dann frage ich dich ob du schon mal von
x-cite gehört hast vermutlich hast du
noch nie davon gehört
dies war aber mal eines der wichtigsten
tal im internet mit zugmaschine
e-mail-dienst rom noch im jahr 1999
wollten page und brin ihr hier muss
google wie die stolze summe von 750.000
ballacks zeit verkaufen etwas richtig
gehört
750.000 dollar ihre firma war ihnen noch
nicht mal eine million wertigkeit lehnte
das angebot trotzdem ab und sind nicht
die einzigen yahoo hat genau das gleiche
getan
beide unternehmen wussten dass der
algorithmus von google etwas bessere
ergebnisse bot als ihr eigener aber so
schlecht liest ja mit den algorithmen
die sie doch als hatten auch nicht warum
also etwas ändern was bereits
funktioniert nun ja drei jahre später
war ich seit wann kommt um dies
vollständig zu verstehen müsste darüber
nachdenken wie weit google von
etablierten normen abwich google
profitiert die ergebnisse basierend auf
dem was du den nutzer wichtig ist dies
mag heute offensichtlich erscheinen aber
zu jener zeit priorisierten
suchmaschinen die ergebnisse nach ihren
eigenen interessen
aber nicht nur das google war die
einzige suchmaschine die sich auf genau
eine sache konzentriert suche yahoo und
viele andere versuchten einen orden
wollen anzubieten
sie wollten den nutzer möglichst lange
auf ihrer seite halten mit einem bunten
angebot sie nachrichten wetter und sogar
spiel mit anderen worten google bot sein
nutzer nur ein einziges produkt an das
aber dafür weit überlegen war
falls die benutzer belohnten google
dafür mit ihrem vertrauen
google wollte sich mit seiner produkt
und unternehmensphilosophie aber nicht
nur von den anderen millionen internet-
unternehmen abheben es wollte eine ganz
andere firma sein als alle zuvor ein
unternehmen für eine bessere welt denn
während manche firmen es vorziehen sich
auf die bewusst destruktive bekämpfung
des wettbewerbs zu konzentrieren dass
sich google seit dem jahr 2000 das motto
don't be evil
also seien nicht bösartig auf die fahnen
geschrieben und nicht nur auf die fahnen
dieses motto wurde ein zentraler punkt
ist internen verhaltenskodex für alle
mitarbeiter google wollte sich damit
bewusst distanzieren und zwar von keinem
geringeren als bill gates von microsoft
der wegen seiner skrupellosen
geschäftspraktiken und rücksichtslosen
profitiert als das erreicht ist lösen
galt das paradebeispiel eines konzerns
mit einer bösartigen und verlogenen
unternehmenskultur in der tat ist google
heute eines der unternehmen das seine
mitarbeiter am besten behandelt und wenn
du wissen möchtest was ein wirklich
schickes frühstück ist dann frag mal
jemanden der bei google arbeitet du
wirst nie im leben ein größeres und
besseres kostenloses bse nun die
wahrheit ist dass diese formel bis zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt für google
sehr gut funktioniert hat als google im
jahr 2004 an die börse gehen war eine
aktie 85 dollar wert mit einer
marktkapitalisierung von 23 milliarden
dollar vergleichbar mit konzernen wie
ford nun heutzutage gegenüber eine
billion dollar
was hat google also getan um so sehr so
wachsen die du weißt ist google
heutzutage ein konglomerat das alle
möglichen dienste anbietet es hat den
meistgenutzten browser der welt
cloud-dienste oft natürlich diesen
dienst
google kaufte youtube für 1,65
milliarden dollar
kurz gesagt google hat die art und weise
wie wir das internet nutzen völlig
verändert sehr eindeutig zum besseren
youtube hat erreicht was teil öffentlich
rechtliche fernsehsender je geschafft
hat die verbreitung von bildungs- und
informationsverhalten anmeldungen von
menschen wollte ich weiß was er isst
alle denkt natürlich mag google hat
unser leben buchstäblich verbessert
wieso machst du dir sorgen über dieses
tolle unternehmen nun das hält nicht nur
mit googles enormer größe zusammen was
ist da bittet auf machtmissbrauch was
genau ist eigentlich aus googles don't
be evil philosophie geworden also im
jahr 2018 wurde diese phrase
klammheimlich aus dem firmeninternen
verhaltenskodex für mitarbeiter entfernt
plötzlich weiß bald google also doch
erlaubt böse zu sein und du fragt sich
wieso nun der weg zum billionen dollar
unternehmen führt unausweichlich zu
konfrontationen
eine der ersten hatte google mit
frankreich genauer gesagt sprechen wir
über den dienst google books die
französische regierung wollte nicht was
ein ausländisches unternehmen ihr
kulturelles erbe digitalisiert also
machte frankreich druck auf brüssel um
eine staatliche version wurde um ebooks
zu schaffen
euro pa dieses projekt ist aber wie zu
erwarten war zu einem kleinen desaster
geworden andere vereine von google sind
die traditionellen unternehmen deren
geschäftsmodell durch das internet ins
wanken gerät ein beispiel dafür ist der
fall von julien jousse gegen die
spanischen medien im jahr 2014
verabschiedet sich die spanische
regierung ein gesetz nachdem portale die
google news eine gebühr an den medien
zahlen mussten wenn ein ausschnitt aus
ihrer nachrichten angezeigt wird
als reaktion war kaum überraschend
google will nachrichtenseite in spanien
wegen urheberrechtsgebühren abschalten
man muss anerkennen dass nur ein teil
der kritik an google vollkommen
berechtigt ist aber es gibt auch
situationen in denen man einen unfairen
vorteil sprechen kann zugunsten von
google ein beispiel dafür
google maps 2005 gegründet aber
natürlich nicht der erste seiner art
wenn du damals eine webseite hat ist und
darin eine karte mit einer angst hat
einbauen wollte ist konntest du einen
dieser dienste nutzen natürlich gegen
eine gebühr aber dann kam google daher
und bot das alles kostenlos an
die folge war dass viele digitale karten
anbieter automatisch und leitet nun
vielleicht sagst du dir das ist doch für
die anwender gut ist wenn sie dieselben
dienst jetzt umsonst nutzen können tja
pustekuchen
ein paar jahre später nachdem google als
seine konkurrenten mit hilfe dieses
dumpings ausgelöst hatte wurde google
maps überraschungen zu einem
kostenpflichtigen dienst zwar ist google
maps für privatanwender noch immer
kostenlos aber die gewerbliche nutzung
der google maps app kostet richtig geld
die französische firma photographs
verklagte google maps deswegen sogar vor
dem trip hineingekommen erst der vorwurf
gegen den tech riesen
wettbewerbswidriges dumping okay was
aber ist dumping genau nun dumping
beschreibt die unrühmliche praxis
kleinere konkurrenten bezieht
auszumerzen
in denen ein großes unternehmen ein
produkt unter einem herstellungspreis
anbietet das große unternehmen hat ja
eine lenkrad wusste und kann verluste in
gedanken statement durch einnahmen aus
anderen geschäftsbereichen
quersubventionieren und das macht es bis
alle kleineren konkurrenten aufgeben
müssen ja und danach hält es ein monopol
und kann die preise so richtig hoch
schrauben
denn der kunde hat ja keine wahl mehr
klingt nicht gerade nach don't be evil
nicht wahr
ein weiteres beispiel ist ein
unternehmen dessen namen du bestimmt
schon mal gehört hast android im jahr
2005 und google erworben läuft sein
betriebssystem heute auf 70 prozent
aller verkauften handy damit hat sich
google selbst zum könig des max für
handy-betriebssysteme gekeult jedes
dieser geräte kann google nutzen um
halle seine dienste zu bewerben und den
ahnungslosen handynutzern aufzudrängen
tja erinnert sich das nicht an einen
ganz anderen fall über den wir am anfang
dieses videos gesprochen haben ein
microsoft sein windows monopol das aller
welt den miesen internet explorer
aufzeichnen wollte heute kommt man ein
android telefon und so fort
gute suchmaschine auf dem homescreen
chrome als standard browser und dem
google app store google cache
standardmäßig vorinstalliert ist google
reichen android 70 prozent marktanteil
jedoch bei weitem nicht wisst ihr von
wem die restlichen 30 prozent des handy
marktes kontrolliert werden genau von
apple mit seinem ios betriebssystem und
mit apple boss tim cook setzte sich 2018
google-ceo sondern biete zusammen um
sich darüber zu unterhalten
die man die werbeumsätze gemeinsamen
maximieren könnte und war schon man
einigte sich google wird auf allen apple
geräten vorinstalliert und zahlt dafür
acht bis zwölf milliarden dollar pro
jahr und apple manager schrieb seinen
google kollegen sogar einer e mail
unsere vision ist es gemeinsam wie ein
unternehmen zu arbeiten
tja wenn das mal kein paradebeispiel ist
für wettbewerbswidrige kartellbildung
zuungunsten des verbrauchers viele
anwender wissen ja noch nicht mal wie
sie die standardmäßig vorinstalliert
suchmaschine erinnern können und auch
wenn sie es wüssten würde es die meisten
einfach aus bequemlichkeit nicht tun
dieser psychologische effekt ist
gewaltig und sehr einfach zu
missbrauchen und genau das war der grund
für die strafe von mehr als vier
milliarden euro welche die europäische
kommission 2018 gegen google verhängt
hat etwas ähnliches passiert mit google
shopping wenn du bei google nach einem
produkt sucht erscheint als erstes jene
produkte die google selbst vertreibt und
das ist der grund warum sowohl europa
als auch die usa so viele forderungen an
dieses unternehmen stellen tatsächlich
ist die klage des us-justizministeriums
gegen google
die größte in der branche seit der
microsoft anklage 98 jedoch sollte diese
klage gegen wird erfolgreich sein wird
sie auch direkte auswirkungen auf andere
bactech unternehmen haben amazon
facebook und apple und was glaubst du
ist das schlimmste das mit google dann
passieren könnte wenn google verliert
wäre es das einfachste eine geldstrafe
zu verhängen
die ist die europäische kommission getan
hat aber in diesem fall stellt sich die
frage ob eine geldstrafe
ein so gigantisches unternehmen wie
google überhaupt gibt deswegen gibt es
auch ganz andere vorschläge wie denen
der us senatorin elizabeth
restaurant sagt sie wolle amazon google
und facebook aufspalten
das thema torex vor google in mehreren
unternehmen aufzuteilen ist lediglich
das erste mal dass so etwas passiert die
größten präsenz fälle sind die
aufspaltung von locke verlass denn der
rolle und at t als der riesige telefon
monopolist usa 1948 musste sich das
unternehmen mehrere kleine unternehmen
aufspalten
welche als baby benz bekannt wurde nein
nicht weil er sie alle käse sind diese
dinge beschreiben sich mit zwei l
die bezeichnung ist eine anspielung an
alexander graham bell den gründer von
konnte man so etwas auch bei diesen
umsätzen
viele kleine baby prinz nun ein größeres
problem könnte darin bestehen dass jedes
dieser mini googles in seiner nähe schon
immer noch ein monopol halten würde dann
müsste diesen firmen dann also auch die
zusammenarbeit untereinander
eine andere option wäre etwas ähnliches
was man damals microsoft verortete
google müsste seinen konkurrenten
direkten zugang zu seiner algorithmen
und plattformen werden und zwar in
wesentlich größerem umfang als bisher
google kontrolliert zum beispiel jeden
einzelnen schritt des komplexen
prozesses der online werbetreibende mit
ihrer zielgruppe den käufern verwendet
wenn es sich in diesem business line
konkurrenten öffnen müsste wäre also
schon viel gewonnen
damit nähern wir uns aber wieder der
frage vom anfangs es ist überhaupt
möglich wirklich mit google zu
kontrollieren selbst wenn der eigene
service viel besser ist als der von
google es versteht sich von selbst dass
eines der hauptargumente der alfabet
anwälte sein wird dass arbeit und seine
tochterunternehmen deswegen in ihrem
monopol position gekommen sind also
einfach die besten produkte haben bietet
das beste an und du gewinnst ein kern
konzeptes kapitalismus allerdings sollte
auch als arbeit nicht vergessen dass
monopole eigentlich für alle schwierig
sind sie führen dazu dass märkte
erstarren innovation für es dadurch auch
das nachfragepotenzial nicht
ausgeschöpft werden kann darunter leiden
dann auch den report ist und seinen
anteilseignern was würdest du dazu sagen
wenn ich dir verrate dass die zuvor
erwähnten aufspaltungen von standard und
alien die dazu geführt haben dass die
börsenwerte und profite der daraus
entstandenen neuen unternehmen noch
schneller stiegen als zuvor überrascht
ist aber so unabhängig von aktuellen
lage wird es vielleicht bald ein
antwort auf diese frage geben die gar
nicht von den regierungen tech firmen
wie spotify und der hersteller von
fortnight versuchen app stores zu
reformieren
sehr wahrscheinlich werden sich mehrere
tech unternehmen denen die hohen
provisionen ubs ein dorn im auge sind
zusammentun um einen eigenen mächtigen
konkurrenten für google clay zu schaffen
und dann werden wir sehen ob sie wird in
seinem eigenen spiel schlagen kann und
wie schwer es denn wirklich ist in
diesem segment mit google zu
konkurrieren
und bis dahin habe ich einfach fragen an
euch glaubt ihr der ansatz der eu
wirkung zeigen fördert google wettbewerb
und kreativität und haben sie einfach
nur pech gehabt dass noch keine
herausgefunden hat wie man es mit google
aufnehmen kann
glaubst du dass eine aufspaltung google
ist allen guttun wird und warum musst du
eigentlich gerade einen dienst von
google schreibt uns bitte alles darüber
gehen die kommentare unter diesem video
basierte auf diese schon sehr gespannt
ich hoffe dass durch dieses video
gefallen und auch etwas gebracht hat
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein leck und
schluss in dem ihr das video mit euren
freunden halt was gut und bis zum
nächsten
[Musik]